bien alors je vais faire un contraste
saisissant
après avoir par les dons de sang sont la
tunisie d'avant champ on va parler alors
du héros de cabu c'est à dire le beauf
le beauf qui nous est représentée ici
par deux albums donc mon beauf et la
france des beaux et on va voir que la si
c'est un français tout à fait
représentatif d'un français bien
différent de fanfan la tulipe et d'henri
rochefort pour d'abord qui sait qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un bon c'est ça veut
dire beau-frère et chaque fois qu'il y
en a dans chaque famille même si les
cousins oncles
c'est le personnage qui qui embête tout
le monde qui titille n'a aucun doute
alors lui il a que des convictions et
qui représente le bon sens français mais
ils sont pas content qu'il ait
complètement manipulé et selon le bon
sens va toujours dans
dans le sens de l'idéologie du moment
des dominantes comme par hasard alors le
premier volume mon beauf à mon avis une
psychologie donc du beau et le second la
france des baux est une sociologie des
beaux arts à ces listes très très fort
c'est vrai c'est le premier bon c'est le
beauf tel qu'il est qu'il second c'est
un beauf qui se déplace à qu'on trouve à
toulouse à lille à marseille à lyon etc
bon d'abord je remarque que le beau fils
et moustachu et il ya toujours une
moustache le final et moustachu au nom
mais il faut oser de la chance explique
nous aider se tiendrait la corde et
n'est pas de moustache parce que vous
savez il faut que je vous dise que je
suis un bon faut s'il en est je crois
que viennent par den bossche tout le
monde nous sommes tous des [ __ ] de
gerbe le dire non c'est à dire quand on
ne fait pas attention
moi aussi je suis un bof c'est à dire
qu'en maintenant quand on a des
réactions sans réfléchir sur tel ou tel
événement
quand on se laisse porter par les idées
reçues on est un beauf mais parce que
bon le thème de votre émission c'est la
france profonde bon gamin non c'était
pas un peu ça le vaut à bout on peut
parler quand ils rochefort sont
représentants de la france tourne pas du
tout en revanche le vôtre oui oui vous
ne pensez que c'est un héros de la
france profonde des années un héros
négatif je reconnais c'est pas c'est
c'est à dire que j'ai fait ça pour qu'on
me défouler parce que dans ce dans ce
monde tout est fait pour eux pour les
baux la musique les automobiles tout la
politique et on est quelques-uns à
chercher désespérément des petits trous
comme les rangs pour se cacher pour
pourvoir quelques quelques plaisirs
il faut il faut les chercher vous savez
parce que tout est fait pour un
archétype du du français
vous priez je sais pas c'est ce que dit
un peu kavanagh alors qu'internet il ya
des moustaches en part par un peu oui
mais à la gauloise à l'angola bon c'est
pas les neuf alors le beau fils à de
l'embonpoint ce type assez costaud oui
oui et c c'est ce personnage qu'on
rencontre dans les cafés surtout oui et
comment ils se comportent dans le café
eh bien je braille juge to ill will
braille il et il est partout chez lui
quoi il fallait il à l'aise il à l'aise
dans cette société les centrales
nucléaires il en faut l'armée tous les
pays en non c'est pas vrai il ya un pays
qui n'a pas d'armée lequel le costa rica
les l'islande mais enfin ils ont une une
base de l'otan
chez eux donc il est parfaitement à
l'aise et il se pose aucune question
alors lui et le grand duduche les
talents de personnages qui a lui-même
qui ne s'entendent pas elle pourrait y
avoir un débat vous devriez le grand
duduche contre vous mais là pour
présenter les deux est souvent ils se
retrouvent dans l'est dans les repas de
première communion par exemple ah bon
qu'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs pas que
les gars je vous dis la conversation
porte sur les centrales nucléaires alors
là vous avez le pour et le contre
bon c'est un chaud lapin le bo a bah oui
parce que il faut bien il faut bien
marquer sa virilité
là aussi tout pour paraître sur tout
voyez ce qui me frappe c'est qu'il est
surtout bien avec son époque
ah oui c'est une époque assez mature
assez
petit bourgeois
si vous voulez mais ce coup par le sait
par exemple que raimu mais un petit côté
un peu beauf en bas non parce que il y
avait un certain génie on peut dire du
génie être un peu mou
non je pense comme témoin ya deux il y à
touba quelque chose moi qui me trompe
c'est un beau parce que le beau vous
avez dit il aime beaucoup la voiture
1 et alors vous vous raconter une
séquence où alors raimu il adore les
voitures raconte et raconte dont il aime
les cas très belles voitures les grosses
voitures américaines il est très fier
d'avoir à une époque que c'est très très
rare en france
quand même un monument américain lequel
il fait des compétitions sur la route
elle ne veut pas que doublé atteignant
paiva et du vélo govou ne veut pas être
doublé 7 et l'âge préhistorique de la
voiture presque vous l'excusé là bas je
crois pas finalement je crois pas que je
dirais millions il a nommé pour sa part
de création chez lui en décompte mon
personnage et 10,9 suis tout le temps
ccc le suiveur c'est une aucune idée
mais alors il ya un espoir quand même
c'est que il commence il commence à se
s'entretuer ces gens là avec l'auto
défense
je sais pas si je vais à la fin de de
ces gens là mais c'est bien parti si ce
tire dessus
bof contre bruit oui les a je crois que
c'était ma belle soeur anne on pensait
times ambrioleur l'averse je crois que
c'est un cambrioleur annonce était ma
belle soeur
mais messieurs ce que vous êtes reconnu
un petit peu dans le beauf de cabu baba
on est toujours le beau de quelqu'un on
a toujours des beaux fut entendue et
enfin ils sont pas tous comme ça
heureusement pas j'irai un peu plus loin
j'ai pas mais on a tous un beau centre
nous
m nous connaissons tous un beauf oui
mais nous sommes tous beaux aussi vous
dire on est tous books d'un autre nom
n'est tous le boss de soi même
mais si on se regarde dans un miroir et
comment on veut y être lucide on
s'aperçoit que bon gré mal gré on est
aussi un beauf un moins bon que le
bouche d'en face en jumelant un peu dur
mais bof quand même fait ma rigolo
participants quand même pas tous je
crois à des années tabou à des préjugés
même si nous les combattants et avec
férocité parfois mais qui sont pas
reluisants mais le bof c'est quand même
l'anti roches peur parce que le bouffe
c'est le conformisme
oui 1 8l sellerie seulement alors et
c'est l'anti fanfan la tulipe
oui oui pour une bonne part or les
enfants latulippe eux apparaît comme un
homme très représentatif des français et
votre beau-frère paraît comme très
représentatif des français car et moi là
dessus mais écoutez il ya des jours où
on dit qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme imbécile sur la terre on
n'arrivera jamais à changer les choses
puis est des jours où on est un peu
mieux et on se dit il était un espoir
peut-être que les jeunes vont vont
changer le monde et tout ça en ce moment
c'est pas c'est mal parti mais votre
beau feu d'après kavanagh il a entre 40
et 50 ans oui mais ce que est ce qu'il y
à déjà complet de bofa 20 ans a tout à
fait j'en ai connu au service militaire
alors là avant et surtout les parisiens
jeu à huy ah oui je sais pas pourquoi
voici le parisien est partout où il est
il se sent le plus intelligent le plus
malin c'est beau oui je sais que les
bourguignons vignerons ils doivent être
un peu beauf ou le monde m'en parle mais
bon d'un côté c'est alors on peut dire
c'est la france profonde
il faut heureusement qu'il ya une france
profonde pour perpétuer les traditions
etc
les racines c'est à la mode en ce moment
mais je constate que cette france
profonde là n'a rien empêché du tout ils
ont adhéré au modèle américain
tout à fait dans les supermarchés ils
mettent les tables en forme de formica
dans les greniers et ils achètent
non c'est le contraire je le contrat oui
oui donc c'est complète c'est un
personnage négatif parce que ne sert à
rien il dit sert à rien pour pour
conserver ce que j'aime moi par exemple
parce qu'il ya des choses que j'espère
humains dans la france profonde
quoi et bien tout ce qui n'est pas
encore bétonné par exemple et ces gens
là aurait pu être un rempart contre ça
mais non basescu alors vous aimerez par
exemple la baguette de pain le béret
basque qui sont très impressionnants ben
oui si le oui moi je suis un passéiste
sûrement oui je tape a fait sûrement
parce que oui mais alors être passé si
est passéiste et 7 contre les centrales
nucléaires contre l'armée et kiss cool
et oui parce que le bohème le progrès ah
oui alors il veut surtout pas être tard
d'un progrès alors il avale tout mais
enfin où des nuances il a jadis c'est
uniquement parce qu'ils payent trop
d'impôts mais alors si vous aviez madame
l'avocate défense de beauf que diriez
vous
je trouve que c'est un abysse est
formidable parce que justement ces
débats on ne perçoit pas moi j'ai
d'autres avis je pense qu on est tous
des beaufs on est tous pas des beaufs et
on regarde les autres en disant c'est
pas tout à fait comme ça ce qui permet
de regarder donc en fait je ne sais pas
je trouve que c'est ce que vous écrivez
est très bien parce que justement a
l'impression de se débarrasser de très
mauvaises habitudes qu'on a de
conformisme de pensée de tous assez
pessimiste finalement derrière sa rue
bailly les bus et oui c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a c'est pour ça qu'on pense pas
complètement la vie du bof quand même
pour ça qu'on n'accepte pas non bien sûr
mais c'est bien c'est bien ça je crois
que l'on connaît tous en tout cas moi je
connais mais nous sommes tous des beaufs
vous avez dit non mais pas ce soir non
c'est pour ça que ça nous rend très
triste d'un coup vous avez
alors on les recrute de quelle
profession plutôt les beaux j'ai
remarqué que vous apprenez plutôt
évidemment militaire sans doute crs on
va recevoir les feuilles feuilles
alors ils les joueurs de lotto s'il vous
plaît pas beaucoup le journal du cedref
offre de jouer au loto
non il y en a partout partout les
chasseurs sont des beau rôle mais pas en
première ligne
ah bon ah oui évidemment juste après les
militaires mais bon parce que ça c'est
cabanas qui dit ça c'est quand même
extraordinaire que les animaux eux ils
ne défilent pas pour regarder passer un
défilé de deux lapins par exemple avec
des couteaux et nous nous y sommes
en fait on fait ça on va défiler le 14
juillet on a défilé le 14 juillet avec
avec nos armes avec avec ce qui va
servir à nous détruire
donc possible que si je vous interromps
paix le viol un pivot c'est un beauf
alors il faut douter alors je réponds
moi je ne sais pas ce que c'est vrai si
je voulais pour hui vous avez raison
vous dit non vous avez peur j'apparais
comme un beauf alors l'importance aux
risques allons allons
tenez je craque n'est pas une commande
ferme dans un deal est oui n'est pas si
l'emploi mais oui c'est un peu trop
c'est en tout cas maintenant au second
empire le recteur goodwill peu été
déportés immédiatement il faut dire que
charlie hebdo n'est possible que dans
très peu de pays dans la france mais
c'est pour ça moi moi j'ai je défends
certains trucs de neutre de nos
institutions par exemple mais je
compense que c'est avec grâce à des
personnages comme henri rochefort que
nous sommes toujours en liberté ou même
peut-être fanfan la tulipe
on a arraché toutes ces libertés il faut
il faut faire attention de les conserver
et je crois que c'est le rôle de charlie
hebdo
quand même très bien marie-france peau
cna à l'heure